learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today the night pants nation
tour is underway thank you arlington for
another great weekend cleveland you are
up next december 9th through the 11th la
jolla you're right after that december
17th through the 19th and austin we're
kicking off 2022 down there january 6th
through the 8th get your tickets now at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media uh again
the night pants nation tour is rolling i
can't thank you arlington enough we had
a great weekend down in arlington up
next we got cleveland december 9th
through the 11th la jolla december 17th
through the 19th and austin texas
kicking off 2022 with you all down there
january 6th through the 8th all tickets
are available at ryanstickler.com
uh please come out see me subscribe to
the email list as well you'll be the
first to know a lot of information
that's going on out there the youtube
continues to grow thank you please hit
that subscribe button we got a lot going
on 2022 is going to be a really big year
uh patreon again this community
continues to grow and grow thank you for
your support i love this show
we are highlighting the lowlights with
y'all and y'all have not let us down the
stories are outrageous and you guys are
very courageous for coming on and
sharing your story so if you or someone
you know has that story has to be heard
please submit the honeydewpodcast
gmail.com you do not need to be a
subscriber to submit um and it's five
bucks a month if you're in for the long
haul you get over a month free and
you're always getting the honeydew a day
early ad-free all right there it is
y'all uh now you know we do over here we
highlight the low lights and these are
the stories behind the stories tellers
uh today very excited to have this guest
on her first time here ladies and
gentlemen please welcome kim kong then
y'all welcome to the honeydew girl thank
you
thank you for being here i'm so happy to
be here i'm excited i am too uh i got to
actually officially meet you finally a
couple weeks ago at the store
and um but you know your homies with my
homies and i knew you were a good person
so before we get into your um low lights
will you please plug promote everything
you'd like of course yeah i had to pull
out my phone because i smoked too much
weed
um uh september 29th i'll be at them
well first of all i should say all of
october i will be in new york
uh for most of october i don't have show
dates yet but i will be getting those on
my social media soon um but september
29th i'm at the american comedy club
with sarah weinshank uh october 3rd i'm
at the creek in the cave in austin texas
october 4th i am doing um death squad
secret show in austin
um october
1st
i will be
doing kill tony and austin and october
5th through 7th i will be at skankfest
houston so a lot of texas and new york
dates if you're out come around and uh
see me and say hi and you're doing ellis
mania aren't you i'm doing ls mania they
don't have a date booked or a location
but i will be fighting in ellis mania
but
you didn't even have your opponent yet
no i don't so that's dangerous yeah it
really is dangerous to go sight unseen
and fight anyway i signed up blindly
which just goes to show where my mental
health is
i can't imagine they could get anyone
they [ __ ] want any chick out there
you're like oh man
um
well before we get into it let me ask
you i'll be fighting caitlyn jenner
[Laughter]
i would be like no did you fight a lot
as a kid or growing up
a little bit i mean
we would like
i thought growing up it was normal to be
like get in fist fights with like your
friends in the woods
yeah i thought everyone did that but
apparently like when i say that people
were like no that's not normal i've
never hit anyone in my life whenever
someone tells me blows me away when
someone hasn't hit someone or hasn't
been hit i'm like well you need to
do both yeah you need to get i talk
about it all the time like even in that
learner's permit series i'm telling my
stepson like look bullying's not okay
but
someone
who checks you for running your [ __ ]
mouth or pushing a little too hard or
just lets you know hey there's bigger
stronger out here careful with where you
step and what you say i think it's a
great [ __ ] thing yeah i'm not talking
about that person kicking your ass every
day i'm talking about somebody who
probably you deserved it and they
[ __ ] punched you right in your god
i've been checked you have you have been
tracked yeah by
i got into i've got a stranger
like sister brother i've been into two
fights okay i've been into two fights
and i've punched one guy in the face
all right i'm gonna get cancelled for
this you're not allowed to say that
anymore but i did you are a woman could
definitely say she points no you can't
not anymore since when dude it's just
like you guys can't rape we can't punch
in the face anymore we were never
allowed to write yes you were
um
so yeah i am
the the first fight i've ever i ever got
how were you 18 17 18 19
fight is night in college
spring break where are you in college
university of florida okay but it's
spring break so we're driving like six
hours i think it was like six hours to
panama city i was just about to say
you're going to panama city of course
we're going to stand on city beach i'm
getting on the bikini contest i'm doing
it all
by the way i went to panama yeah i was
19 because when i was 18 i made the
mistake of bringing my boyfriend with me
that's when i did the bikini contest and
i was a whole he was there he was not
i was just like on the beach with my
friends and he was somewhere else with
his friends and they were like come do
this contest you can win money and i got
second place which is really sad how
much money did you get um i think like
200 bucks that's [ __ ] so exciting
yeah that's a lot of money in college
especially in spring break
i brought home the money like a [ __ ]
hooker
i was so proud dude we lived in a very
small town i thought it was like the
coolest thing um
[Laughter]
i thought it was like something to be so
proud of um and it truly ruined spring
break for us and all our friends
you're friends too like it was ugly the
rest of the time it was constant
fighting
um but what if you'd won first what if
you'd won first they would have been
different then i could have taken out
the dinner at least
[Laughter]
that was my first and last bikini wait
but then you said but the next year that
the next year i went back again with my
friend this is a girl whose friends were
in college and this girl was
a problem
like i probably shouldn't have been
hanging out with her she was just
loved meeting guys a problem and i was
always like the kind of like friend that
wouldn't [ __ ] and would be like i would
be like she sucks like your friend sucks
she don't [ __ ] like you my friend was
like getting trains ran on her and i was
like that's not me like i don't know um
so we went to spring break and she was
like i was like i don't have money for
spring break
i'm poor i'm in college and she's like
it's fine we'll figure it out so we
drive the six hours
and we're at the beach and we're having
fun and there's a concert happening and
i meet this guy on the beach she's like
off doing her own thing who knows and i
meet this guy on the beach and he's like
flirting with me super cute i'm really
excited about it he puts me on his
shoulders for the concert and we're just
having fun like i'm not doing anything
crazy
and probably like 20 minutes into that a
girl comes up and starts arguing with
him while i'm on his shoulders
and she's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
and then she looks at me and she's like
that's my [ __ ] boyfriend and i was
like oh [ __ ] and she takes [ __ ] on
his neck
boyfriend's
yeah
on him so i think it's my boyfriend
i'll mark this [ __ ] i definitely
at least leaked a little i sneezed up
here twice
um
[Laughter]
so i so sh then she takes a coors light
can that wasn't open and she just from
like
two feet away just chucks it at my face
as hard as she can and it smacks me in
the nose yeah and i don't even expect
the tea can
dude you guys
i got she teased me no offense coors
ladies proud sponsor the honey dude for
real really yeah
if you had to get hit with any beer
is it really
this is yeah i appreciate you here
i appreciate you being so funny
well it tasted great
i mean that's a brick dude [ __ ] brick
and that's close and not close and
where'd it hit you today it hit my teeth
out in my nose and in my eye like
knocked me in the face and it shocked me
but before i had time to think i came
back up i could take a smack my mom's
puerto rican
so but i came back up and the dude had
grabbed me by the ass and thrown me on
top of her nose like he was sick of her
[ __ ]
yes and so i land on top of her and
naturally we just start fighting hit her
[Laughter]
just some random [ __ ] at this point the
music stops
the entire beach is like circled around
us and we're fighting and then i can
feel her friend hitting me in the head
with a beer bottle jesus christ so then
someone drags me and i'm doing pretty
well at this point i'm on top of her
because i remember being like dragged by
my feet off of her and you're in a
bikini is she in a bikini those are
bikinis my body i hadn't eaten carbs in
two weeks like
i was i just went you were ready the
year before i knew what was up i was
like there's money on the table out here
so i can't remember more you should have
charged for this
i'm sure this video's out there
somewhere i think i flashed my tits i
went out that spring break it was truly
not me um
yeah and then uh we get dragged away i
have like this big cut on my face so i'm
like the girl that fought on spring
break i keep seeing people all weekend
being like you're the girl that fought
but when i was getting dragged away i
got to look at the girl i saw who she
was she did i saw her face as i was
being dragged i looked up and i remember
her face and i was like whatever right
so you know spring break happens we go
back home this is early in spring break
like this is the first stage first day
you and your face is [ __ ] up for
spring break [ __ ] up we're not even
[ __ ] up i have a like a scratch are
you still gonna be able to do the bikini
contest no i i i was like you know what
i'm out i'm not gonna be called stars
you know what i mean like
yeah i had to
she owes me that money i think
so then
i um
so you spotted her face spring break's
over spring rake's over drive six hours
back to uf
three weeks later i go to this thing
called techno tuesday that they would
have
and if you are going to uf
from the years of
2009 to 2012 you know techno tuesday
everyone went even if you didn't listen
to techno everybody went to techno
tuesday it was super fun um and when i
was at techno tuesday and i was walking
towards the bathroom and i see that
[ __ ] no way the same girl that hit me
um
and i
i
was pretty drunk at this point and all i
just remember is her hitting me for no
reason so i went up to her she was
waiting by the bathroom in the line
outside in the hallway by the bathroom
and i just hit her as hard as i could in
the face
[ __ ] yeah what happened and as soon as i
hit her i got [ __ ] clocked
by one of her friends a girl or a guy a
girl but but let me tell you it was do
you watch basketball you know who doc
rivers is yeah
oh i don't know if i can say this
i don't want to be sued
anyways
she hit you someone hit me related to
doc
no
not at all i don't even think doc rivers
has a daughter
i don't know
the idea but um this girl is on the
volleyball team
and uh she [ __ ] hit me in the eye
really hard and gave me a huge black eye
um and i but you got yours in there i
got mine in but it was not worth it for
me yeah it hurt so bad my eye hurts so
bad i thought i was gonna go blind
like i was couldn't see out of it for a
couple days i was like there could be
damage you know what i mean um and i
remember the girl contacted me she found
me on social media she asked me for my
number i gave it to her and then she
called me and she was like let's not she
was like i didn't know we went to the
same school let's not do this every time
we see each other
and i was like cool i'm good with that
and that was the end of it
and that's what the two fights i was in
damn and then both with the same girl
yeah both with the same crazy and in a
different location at a different city
in a diff six hours away
by a bathroom i was like god gave her to
me
like here it is
that's how god works
um
so
yeah and then i punched one guy in the
face at the comedy store oh at the
comedy store when i i told the story
you're allowed to say who
i don't know i don't want to say a comic
or a guest it was i think he was a comic
i don't know if he still is he was this
douchebag i was dating when i first
moved to la who was like a model trying
to be a comic
um and he was an [ __ ] and i think we
were like in the middle of like a like a
sort of we would we were like on and off
again for nine months and we were like
in a fight currently but both at the
store drinking and i was hanging out
with my friends and he was being mean to
my friends on purpose just trying to
make them uncomfortable and then i
started making fun of his comedy and
people started laughing and he got
really upset and he like poked me in the
shoulder while he was talking to me he
was like don't you ever do like he was
like
and so i punched him in the face in the
face [ __ ] yeah i gave him a big black
eye i punched him and a few people saw
him they're like what the [ __ ] and then
i just walked away and then i was
sitting in the back like like just
chilling and he came by with an ice pack
with the manager and the manager was
like
i think it was richie
he came back with richie and richie was
like who didn't know was it richie maybe
i don't know and richie was like who did
it and he looks me straight and i was
like i don't know some kind
and then he didn't sell me out and that
was the only time i punched someone but
he deserved to be punched don't poke me
well yes that's that's the same thing
you're touching me don't touch me don't
[ __ ] touch me yeah
all right so let's dive into i
appreciate you telling me about your
fights yeah your fights and your
aggressiveness and i hope you do well
whatever they [ __ ] pair you again
against in that because i really do want
to go i talked to ellis about it and i
want to go to it did he say that they're
looking for someone what do you say no
he said they're looking for the venue
right now still trying to lock the venue
yeah
um
you're gonna get somebody like the night
before they're gonna be like can you do
this yeah let's see
good because i'm going to be training
from now i know i love it i've been
watching you out there training
so tell me about um are you from florida
then i am all right so tell me about
your family and your upbringing because
i know you've got some wild stories yeah
my family is uh [ __ ] insane um
have you ever seen i like to describe
have you ever seen the show shameless of
course they are
almost
that okay like exactly that but if like
the house was cleaner so you're tricked
does that make sense like books put
together but like it's a mess on the
inside like it's a nightmare
my dad is frank my dad's like very much
frank like christmas mornings he'd come
over my dad and my stepdad are friends
all right so your mom and dad were were
they married when you were born
no okay so tell me about that
how many how many siblings do you have i
have three younger sisters younger okay
two half sisters okay and one sister
with my mom and my dad okay
and then they both split up and had kids
with someone else okay so those are the
two half sisters your mom had kids with
someone else and your dad had kids or
something my mom had a kid with someone
else and my dad had a kid with someone
else so those are my two half sisters on
each side and then there's me and my
sister from my my my mom and my dad and
how were you when they split uh five
five but they were never married or they
were they were married yeah they got
divorced
they got divorced when i was five i
think they got married when i was like
three or two
okay
but continued to have
was so is your sister with them younger
than you
or older than you they got divorced then
they had my sister they did you know
what i've never even realized that
that's why i was wondering like wait a
second
wait a minute
they just [ __ ] one time five years
later oh it's five years difference yeah
so wait me and my sister my the sister
that's closest to my age is five years
younger than me how about so they just
[ __ ] five years after they divorced
but how about the kids they had with
their that's five more years after that
okay so they weren't cheating those kids
are older than your five-year-old that
was close
that was close because this is kind of
juicy but that would have been like i
need to make some phone calls the
holidays are almost here so for all of
you who are trying to figure out what to
get that person who means so much to you
i've got the perfect gift enzo rings
these are stylish silicone rings with a
soft flexible fit they're so much more
comfortable and safer than wearing a
metal ring especially for anyone
active or who works with their hands a
lot
they sent me a few of these and i like
them man these are easy they slide on
and off really easy it's
look at that
it's durable
it's uh it looks good you can't even
tell all right so no matter what your
taste our enzo rings has you covered
with a wide selection of stylish and fun
collections like their elements
collection that has an elegant look of
real metal but the benefits of silicone
enzo rings actually infuses real
precious materials into the silicone and
you can't find that in any other
silicone ring brand there's platinum
there's rose gold diamond pearl even
volcanic ash plus many more trust me
enzo rings are a gift that they'll love
check out enzo's elements rings and
other best sellers at my special url
enzorings.com honeydew and for a limited
time you get 10 off your first purchase
of any collection when you use the promo
code honeydew don't wait lock in your
holiday orders now and even get one for
yourself for 10 percent off that's promo
code honeydew at e n s o rings.com
honeydew look you know we live in one of
the most expensive cities in the world
here los angeles i still rent renting's
you know it's a pain and it's
ridiculously expensive here and i know
you can own a home anywhere else for the
amount we pay in rent here so i want to
buy and i highly recommend if you do too
checking out the how to buy a home
podcast it's an amazing resource for
anyone interested in taking steps
towards home ownership the host david
cedoni has been helping first-time home
buyers like us for years his how to buy
a home podcast can help you determine if
home ownership is the right investment
for you whether it's now next year or in
five years plus the podcast will arm you
with the knowledge to qualify for loans
with only 3.5 percent down navigate
bidding wars pick the perfect realtor
and so much more if you want a free
playbook for buying your first home then
listen to the how to buy a home podcast
today find how to buy a home wherever
you listen to podcasts like many of you
i am fed up with uh the insurance we get
today it sucks you know i pay almost 600
bucks a month and it's basically just
emergency insurance i'm still paying 10
000 out of pocket it's ridiculous i've
maxed out before and it can be crushing
you know so when it comes to health care
it's important to make sure you're
getting your money's worth so while
you're shopping around don't forget to
head to joincrowdhealth.com
fit to find out how crowd health can
save you 40 to 60 in health care cost
each year it's not health insurance what
it is is it's a modern way to pay
medical expenses crowd health is a
community of people who are tired of
paying into a broken system being in the
crowd health community can save hundreds
of dollars monthly and put thousands of
dollars back in your pocket crowd health
gets rid of the insurance middleman and
passes the savings to its members 100 of
your monthly membership pays for actual
health care costs helping the whole
crowd health community stay healthy
while keeping more money in your pocket
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members but they have
an amazing offer just for my listeners
get your first six months for just 99 a
month that's a savings of almost 50
percent versus their standard pricing
and a lot less than one of those crappy
high deductible plans just go to
joincrowdhealth.com
99 and enter code honeydew sign up
that's join crowdhealth.com 99 promo
code honeydew crowd health is not health
insurance it's a community-powered
alternative terms and conditions may
apply so you're just for real realizing
that now okay they must
i've never even thought about it i think
they did the that night that they got
together what what's your sister's month
birth month april so what's nine months
before oh why do you got make me do it
i can't do that that's four months to
january and then let's see july august
how can you do that backwards september
august september october november
december january march april may no so
july
4th of [ __ ] july 4th of july
fireworks baby
they got together that's violence yeah
oh that's definitely what it was well i
was conceived on they missed like
holidays because my birthday september
25th which is nine months after
christmas day there you go so they love
a holiday they do they love a good
holiday
good holiday [ __ ]
so they [ __ ] and then your sister comes
out five years later okay but they're
not
but they're when you say they're
separated you guys are living in
different places too right
dude no i mean
i don't know
i can't remember what
i can't remember
if they're
who did you know he
he was living with us when my sister was
born
but they were already filed for divorce
i think they were like separated
separated and maybe trying to figure it
out again sure i think that was the case
maybe or whatever it is then they're
like now we have a kid and then i think
like a year after my sister was born oh
no that's when it was official
this is when things get juicy
so
yeah after
after my sister was born
i was five this is what it is i'm just
high
i can't
it's so high you knew all your fight
stories inside i was like yeah this one
i block out yeah i would imagine uh this
is worse than a black eye
yeah my sister was about one and my dad
who's a fisherman
um
when you're a commercial fisherman you
leave for like a while at a time like he
would go to like puerto rico and go
fishing and stuff like that
um or wherever it was legal
um and um
my mom met my stepdad
out one night while he was gone fishing
i see yeah she was a cheater
and i remember my mom cheated at least
we that we know of first and i remember
i knew nothing about it like i'd never
seen him before but there was one
morning when i walked into my mom's room
and there was someone with really long
hair in my mom's bed and i thought it
was a woman
and i was like who's that and my mom was
like it's your aunt who didn't have long
hair so it was just kind of confusing
and
see this is i feel like i must have been
like
yeah i must have been like
not seven eight you're on
seven or eight maybe and i was just like
this kind of doesn't make sense
and then my my dad came home and i
remember they were arguing and he was
like kim have you seen anyone here and i
was like
that that lady that was here with the
long hair was my aunt right
and that's like how i said it oh no yeah
and that and he was like oh really and i
remember him being like oh really your
aunt was here and he was like it wasn't
like anything bad but like i remember
that moment of him being like
i was like oh i think i sold her out but
good i remember being like but good
why did you did you have a favorite then
no i just was like
you're lying
you know when you're a kid you're like
you're not supposed to lie yeah right of
course you should get in trouble so what
happens then
um then they get a divorce
my mom meets my stepdad
um and my mom and my
well first of all
my family you should meet my mom and my
aunt now they're
bad
they're bad what do you mean
they're tell me there's something wrong
i don't know what happened with them
when they're younger but if you ask my
cousins like
i didn't realize that i had like a crazy
childhood until like i came out to l.a
and i would like do or say things
and they'd be like no that's not normal
no other families don't do that my mom
my aunt got into a fist fight with women
three months ago
how old are they they're in their 50s
they're in their 50s
what are they fighting over my step dad
my mom and my stepdad have been trying
now these two get together these two
[ __ ] hate each other okay so
hold on let's go back for a second your
mom cheats on your dad with my stepdad
stepman the guy with the long hair and
these [ __ ] just fight they get
married though
yes
and i think i think 10 years after they
meet they get married okay but he's in
your life now at this point yes from
there and i don't like him okay and i
never and i don't like him i instantly
remember all that [ __ ] i realize he's
the same person from the whole thing and
it makes me not like him right and my
sister is like living with your mom
when they split i'm living with my mom
yeah and how often are you seeing your
dad
now my dad turns into
a weekend dad
okay yeah and he's also fishing
sometimes too so he's like gone yes and
i think that there's like a lot of like
my mom's trying to make my stepdad my
dad type thing right you know
um and i do not like my step-dad at this
point the first time we met
we played break the ice and he
aggressively
i don't know how to explain my stepdad's
personality but do you know the the the
brother from step brothers that has the
family in the car
that's how my stepdad is so i remember
the first time we met we played break
the ice and he really won
like i'd never had an adult be like yeah
like
[Laughter]
but like really from his heart not even
like
you know sometimes i talk [ __ ] to kids
to like make them better people but this
was like he really was happy that he won
against me and i was so offended that i
was like in my head i'm a kid and i'm
like you're an adult you shouldn't be
winning this hard against me i
understand and and he didn't get that
and i didn't like him from then on it
became like a whole thing um and we
didn't get along at all growing up we
get along better now
okay so he's still because i'm gone are
you still with your mom though they just
got a divorce wow okay
a few months ago and this is where the
the fight comes in this is where the
fight comes in again
but the fight's been there but they um
they're just together for years they
fight all the time
they don't really like each other and
it's like it is what it is and i'm like
for me i growing up i didn't really i
was like okay this is how how people's
lives are and then i would go to my
friend's house and i'd be like oh your
parents don't like they like each i'd
see their parents kiss and i'd be
weirded out i'd feel like it was
something inappropriate like i wasn't
supposed to look isn't it that's why i
went to people's houses all the time
like oh your mom gives you hugs huh
yeah nobody's over here yelling at you
yeah wait you didn't just get a shoe
thrown at you because you didn't put it
over there by the door like yeah like
that doesn't come flying at your head
because you left it in the sink totally
yeah yeah
so um
i go away to college and well i mean
they're just still together there's not
much story they're just together and
fighting for years but my they're trying
to break up constantly since i'm in high
school
till now
they've been trying to break up they
keep getting back together keep breaking
up keeping them active the whole family
knows it's a whole it's a thing that's
what they're known for is like they
always break up and get back together
and my my dad my stepdad has a band
what's he play um he's the lead singer
oh yeah can he sing yeah he can sing
well he yeah he can sing
i don't know if he can sing now he used
to be able to sing years ago but i don't
really listen anymore but he does he has
a band they like um they like
book
like local
are they good are they all right are
they a cover band they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're they're
they're
they're
they're
they're
rich
um they they sound like good like like
if you know my town they sound good
they're like perfect for my town
okay you know what i mean it's a small
town they do the the right songs
every people dance people have fun
people get drunk but it's also like
old motorcycle bars like and [ __ ] like
that um so he has a band so
this becomes a huge problem when they
break up because my stepdad goes out and
there's like old drunken groupies in her
hometown
and my mom keeps showing up this is
currently my mom just keeps showing up
to his band things and being like and
bringing a bunch of friends so it's fun
so she he like he always calls me he's
like i don't know how to tell her to
stop because then when she doesn't she
like brings a bunch of people she makes
it she's so smart and so manipulative so
she knows how to get there and how to be
welcome like if she brings enough people
the whole band's gonna be like yeah have
her keep coming she makes it like a
party
um but she does it so she can make sure
that he's not talking to girls
so one night
he doesn't
he doesn't invite her to a show and
she's like that's weird so she goes out
with her sister and whenever they're out
drinking together
they're like criminals dude there
anything can happen i just wait for a
phone call from jail like it's like
you've had that yeah we're coming back
to that i mean i want to hear it just
know i mean like i've just had people in
my family going to jail but yeah uh
you're gonna hear it this is what it's
leading up to
um but
my mom and my aunt are out and oh i
should tell you my aunt starts dating
the the the bass guitarist from the band
so now they're both being crazy
and then
[Laughter]
and the guy in the band in my aunt fight
all the time too i think the guy in the
the bass guitars is on meth and it's a
huge problem with them obviously
he's wearing my grandpa's jewelry that
he stole on his neck and he's like
and his and is denying that it's my
grandpa's we have to look at it every
[ __ ] day while he's got no teeth
playing the bass guitar and
i'm wearing it in front of you that's
ridiculous
so
[Laughter]
it says larry on it man your name is
[ __ ] candy goddamn that hates sure
right it's still on my grandpa
um so
so yeah that she starts dating the the
guitarist and they start showing up to
the shows together it's a huge problem
there are constantly problems and then
affects the band now the band's fighting
sure yeah these two sisters are coming
in and causing issues
so my aunt my sister get a call one
night that the guys had a show
and after the show these two young girls
came back to my step-dad's house
which my mom's moved out at this point
in living in an apartment complex this
is a few months ago who's calling who's
who's the tip there's i don't know they
got tips it's a small town yeah yeah
there's a small they got their feelings
they got a hotline
yeah dude you can't go nowhere without
these [ __ ] coming we call them the
storm me and my cousin call them the
storm because it feels like the wind
picks up like when they're on their way
like the wind picks up like have you
ever had the eye of the storm where it's
like eerily calm yeah right in the
middle dude we're like the storm's
coming me and my cousin will say like
even when we were like 10 11 when they
were about to get crazy we were like the
storm's about to i smell a storm a broom
my cousin's one of me and my cousin i
think it made us funny
seeing our moms
i mean
they are my mom our moms were 21 and 22
or my aunt was
19 or 20 when she had my cousin which
could have almost been vanilla ices
because she
long story was either this dude or
vanilla ice cream yes
your cousin there was a moment where
possibly vanilla ice could have been her
dad the best way i could bully my cousin
growing up was going up to him and going
ice ice
baby i would do it and he would get so
pissed he would chase me and try to hit
me he'd be like stop vanilla ice
baby yeah
um
but um so my my aunt was 19.
no no no we found the guy it was a local
band okay a guy in a local band who we
could never find again because there was
no internet and then we found him on
facebook a few years ago a few years ago
like eight years you've tracked her dad
down his my cousin's dad yeah his dad
yeah
we'll come back to that we're still
we're still the storm's just about the
storms are brewing
so they get the tip
so they get the tip and um what my
sister tells me my sister haley is like
very sweet and very normal and shouldn't
even be in our family she should be off
with a nice white family somewhere
you know
experiencing a good life with a fence
and a dog um and she's just coming from
a white family
i mean there is no fence you can walk
right over you know
watch the nails
um okay yeah so my sister haley tells me
that my step-dad and and and his friend
do bring a couple girls over and they
and she was like but everybody was just
having a good time like they're all
drinking
my sister lives there she's still in
high school at this point and so and
she's like um dad even brought them out
blankets and put out pulled out the
futon so they could pass out on it and
then at this point the futons pulled out
and my dad's my stepdad's made a bed so
if the girls do feel like they need to
stay they didn't feel like they needed
to stay with him my sister was like dad
was being so nice to them blah blah and
then my mom and my stepdad come through
the door step dad i mean my mom and my
aunt
come through the door
my mom has a key still she refuses to
give up the key so there's no never he
won't change the storm
and he likes it i think he likes it
dude he's like it's like he's into it
and because the fact that he has we've
been telling him for 10 years i should i
mean my sister's been like 10 years old
be like get a restraining order you
idiot like we've all been like [ __ ]
stop
but he likes it um so she comes
beats my sister's like they just started
beating up the girls wait these girls
are laying on a futon no they're just
sitting in the back porch having a night
cap music's playing my stuff down and
the basses are giving them a little they
just start getting their own car and
they just start getting their ass kicked
by these two old puerto rican women
who are just drunk as [ __ ]
like
i don't know if i should be telling the
story
my sister says that what she sees she
comes out of the room she sees my aunt
and my and my mom each have a girl and
by the feet
and they're dragging them out and one
girl's reaching for her shoe my sister
goes and runs and gives it to her
drag him out and throw him locked the
door on
the girls that didn't they were waiting
for their keys my sister had to sneak
their keys out to them they were hiding
like it was it must have been like get
out for them they're like hiding behind
the car waiting for their kids to give
up we don't know
they had no idea a storm was approved
that's just the beginning i'm sure your
step back got a [ __ ] bunch of it too
oh my god i don't know what happened the
rest of the night oh my god
but that was bad that was a bad one
and so you know after that they
my stepdad was like this is crazy you
know they didn't see each other for a
little bit but then they always do this
thing and they're like we're friends
we've been because they've been together
since i was five i'm i'm 30. i'm about
to be 31 so they've been together for 26
years a very long time so they're also
in love so i don't know how they show it
weird and they've shown no affection but
they do love being around each other i
don't understand it it's a weird toxic
love is how i see it um
and i think they're both just afraid to
like leave or change they're both two
people that are super scared of change
um i remember my stepdad being like uh
cause i was because he was getting paid
for his spot and he was like oh yeah we
get paid a few hundred bucks
and i do just a few around he's like i'd
love to do this like as my career and i
was like why don't you just book more
places
then quit your job just make up maybe
make a little less but if you love doing
this you don't like doing your job just
like sacrifice a little bit of money and
just do this forever you you're gonna
you've been working forever and he's
like no i could never
and i'm like but if you get paid why not
and that's the way i see things but i
think they're both like very
set in their ways and and glad to be
together um
but
they they don't see each other for a
while independently codependent but all
toxic exactly yeah yeah so my mom's
doing this thing where like they they're
they have adorable they give they
officially sign the divorce papers it
takes so long me and my sisters are like
we're cutting you both off until you
sign the papers you can be together but
we're not going to talk to either of you
we're we're all sick at this point we're
all sick of it we're like put them all
in jail please get them out of our face
um and um
and they still see each other they just
like can't stop seeing each other and my
mom has a boyfriend and she's still
going to my stepdad shows
and i remember they still hook up
i don't know probably
is what i'm getting but your mom has a
boyfriend does he have a girlfriend now
he doesn't have a girlfriend she doesn't
let him have a girlfriend but she has a
boyfriend because she'll come over and
chase the [ __ ] out of that he tried
to have a girlfriend and she tried he
tried to have a girlfriend and my mom
found her phone number and called her
and i think threatened her
so
it's not funny it's abuse
it's abused she's abusing him
abusing her this is abuse she's abusing
him but look if you take it for 20 years
you get what you deserve
but if you were saying that to a woman
it'd be horrible it would be horrible
but also if you stayed for 20 [ __ ]
six years of any person i don't care
what sex you are or what you identify as
you gotta go you gotta [ __ ] go yeah
it's time to go okay i'm no i'm in no
way saying that someone should do this
to you
but if you know i don't know maybe five
years
you know what's your limit it's not it
ain't a year for me you know but 26
years he is definitely going to keep
getting it six months is my limit six
months is like the farthest i'll go now
just simply changing the locks that have
been something if you would have changed
the locks
no windows breaking whatever then the
police come there that's your fault yeah
exactly yeah i got a peaceful night
sleeping thank you for that window
except for the window
um so tell me about your um locating
your cousin's uh father then but did he
not know or would he just bounce well
before this happens my mom finds my
stepdad recently
at his show and she texts me when i'm on
my way to joshua tree this is the last
part she talks to me and she texts me
because sometimes i just don't answer
she's too much she texts me emergency
and i'm like [ __ ] this is it someone's
died i always wait for that call you
know and i answer and she's like oh my
gosh your stepdad's in jail and i was
like what happened and she's like well i
went to a show and i was like that's it
it starts there i don't want to hear it
and she's like well he pushed me down
and i'm like good
he should beat you up you are stalking
him
literally i was like you should be in
jail stop stalking him i he should have
beat you harder
am i wrong for that i mean you can say
you can only stalk a man for so long
yeah 26 years you're 20 60 years all he
did was shove you down
please he should have shoved you down a
few times
um why did he shove her because she
showed up and probably was being crazy
at a show no
he's just trying to do his show man he's
just trying to sing my black guy
you know he works in nine to five and he
just wants to do a show at the country
club down the street please and live in
peace
let that man live
um so he ends up all the time he ends up
going to jail dude he gets the brunt of
it
your mom's beating people whatever so
ever since then we cut my mom off and
now she's like
i want to change
she's decided to go she says she's gone
sober she hasn't drank she's off
antidepressants and she's going to do an
ayahuasca trip oh [ __ ] okay
so we'll see how that goes
i was like what you should just try
therapy and she's like nah ayahuasca's
therapy in one weekend that's exactly
what she's leaving now i'm just gonna do
all that work in two days yeah my
therapist is like she doesn't want to do
the work that's good that's good
healthy
um but yeah so my cousin's yeah cousin's
dad
so was he just a musician that bounced
early on or did he not know that he ever
got i mean imagine he had no idea really
he didn't know it mm-hmm was he not a
local guy it was a one-night stand and
they were touring in puerto rico they
were like my aunt described them as like
an up-and-coming band that like
everybody knew
and my mom and her
the other thing for the band the storm
loved the bands i see my mom pictures of
with my mom with um
pantera
yeah
and um uh rage against the machine
and i'm like what are you what were you
doing after hours at the uh
sitting on a pool table with rage
against the machine she's like oh they
were my friends i'm like where are they
were they your friends were you [ __ ]
them
um but yeah my they went to go see um a
local band and i think my aunt had a one
night stand
then the band left and i think that
probably wasn't easy to locate a touring
band
with no internet in 1989
um
and
so what how did you find them
uh so
were you look was he looking for him um
we
i love that it was either this guy or
vanilla ice dude so it's i love it they
love the musician
you know and right now i am uh one of
vanilla ice's
someone that works on his tour i don't
know if he's like an assistant or
something he follows me and all the time
he'll invite me things but i'm just like
always busy when he invites me or i'll
be gone he's like come to the vanilla
ice thing and i want to just to tell him
that he was almost my cousin's dad
almost my cousin's dad it was you or
another dude
um
but um
my cousin just starts asking questions
about his dad once we and me and my
cousin grew up together like my mom
um and and her sister like always bought
houses next to each other or they you
know we lived in like uh what are those
things are like split
the town house yeah something like that
or duplex duplex so we don't live
together yeah all the storms stayed
together the storm never stops a bruin
dude
it never ends it's under the same roof
yeah that's how they get electricity
when they're together it's
me and my cousin
now that we're adults you should see our
faces we're like ugh
these two
um but
so me and my cousin were super close
he's so when when we started getting
like myspace and stuff i started i think
my cousin or my aunt found a clipping in
her childhood stuff of the
the tour and she could never remember
the guy's name wow
one night and she found a clipping of
the band she remembered the name of the
band
and um it had the guy's name in it and
then so we started looking up
uh i think at that point i had facebook
myspace
facebook i think it was facebook and i
started looking him up and i couldn't
find anyone i couldn't find anyone so
then i just started using his last name
and i started just
sending my aunt and my cousin a bunch of
people that could look like my cousin
and we found this one girl who looked
just like my cousin no way yes i like
way deep down in all of and the last
name was kind of specific it was like
italian
and so it was like
mostly in one area and we found one girl
that looked just like her and they
contacted him and it was the guy and
that we asked her
if her dad was this guy's name and if he
was in this band she said yes and it was
him
and then they uh he was floored to he
had no idea he had no idea he had a wife
and kids they live in jersey um
really nice and he did a dna test and
everything um and then he sent over a
dna test wow good um my cousin did a dna
test and it matched um and then he
bought him like right away a plane
ticket to come um see him and meet him
and my cousin was so happy because he
had wanted a dad his whole life yeah now
he has this guy who's like a great guy
telling him he wishes he knew the whole
time yeah that's awesome it's super
sweet uh he got to meet his grandfather
who passed away i think a year later so
that's nice how old when he how was your
cousin when he finally met him i'm 17 or
18. damn wow all right so there's plenty
of time left there's plenty of time so
now they go every year and see him my
cousin has almost three kids now
two and a half does um
does his father know about how bad the
storm is and no i think they leave him
out of it you know mike i think my
cousin's done a good job of being like
your aunt never talked to him or said
hello no i think she did i think they
talked on the phone or facetime she
didn't go with him to meet him i don't
think that's necessary but
she did like you know they contact each
other and it's nice that's awesome yeah
it's really great great story
it's super sweet
um
so well you said your mom is a
narcissist and your dad's an alcoholic
so let's i want to hear more of this
[ __ ] this is good
um i feel like i should have should be
paying you for this
you're good girl you guys get deep on
this podcast huh yeah um yeah i mean my
dad like i said he's like frank
gallagher from shameless like i remember
i think a few christmases ago he he
comes over every christmas because
they're him and i stepped at one point
when my mom moved out my dad
moved
this pop-up camper that my mom
my mom and my stepdad let him borrow a
pop-up camper and he had it in the in
the in this campsite he was living in it
and that was his house that was his
house
and
he my dad's just
i if you ask me where he lives right now
i i think a boat
i think he is fixing up
fish or is he retired now just bought a
boat
um
uh with his with his uh
pandemic
stimulus
his stemi he got him he he had no he had
no unemployment then i helped him do it
and so he got like three months back pay
at one so he got like 15 grand and went
and bought a boat he'd never had that
much money at the same time so he went
and bought a boat and now he he's naming
his boat the nancy pelosi
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and um
where was i going with him oh yeah so uh
so he comes over during holidays and
hangs out and he he even moved in with
my stepdad at one point he
the pop-up camper got destroyed in a
storm
um and a lightning bolt hit a tree this
one my dad said
a lightning bolt hit a tree the tree
fell over and it broke the top of the
camper and so he wheels this broken
camper back and he's like i'm gonna just
keep it here and live in it and my mom's
like all right um so he spends like
christmas with us christmas eve with us
gets so drunk when christmas eve falls
asleep by the fire outside
we wake up on christmas morning my mom
was like go wake up your dad in the yard
so we can open presents
i have to go
nudge them it's just like old smoke and
like morning do i'm like it's christmas
get up santa cane and he's like
your old dad did it again huh i'd say oh
god but he's friends with your stepdad
yeah and he's also
so funny they sound like they're good
guys
like for them to at least get along
they're
the thing that's [ __ ] up about my
family is they're all good people i know
i'm saying horrible things about them
but like they're all trying they're all
really trying to be good people but they
just had [ __ ] up childhoods too and
they didn't work on themselves and and
that wasn't cool when they were kids or
when they were adults and now we're in
this time where it's like working on
ourselves
fight people yeah exactly yeah so um
they're all trying to be cool but
they're so [ __ ] up but it also makes
them very interesting
like it's not boring at our house ever
good health starts with good habits quip
makes it easy by delivering all the oral
care essentials you need to care for
your mouth the quip electric toothbrush
is loved by over 7 million mouths and it
has thyme sonic vibrations with 30
second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended 2 minute clean it's got a
lightweight and sleek design with no
worries or bulky charger to weigh you
down beyond the brush quip has
everything you need to build a complete
routine it's got anti-cavity toothpaste
in mint or watermelon that helps prevent
cavities it's got refillable mouthwash
that's four times concentrate plus it's
good for you and the planet with stylish
and affordable electric brushes starting
at just twenty five dollars if you go to
get quipped dot com slash honeydew right
now you'll get your first refill for
free that's your first refill free at
get quip dot com slash honeydew i'm
gonna spell it for you
g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com slash honeydew
quip the good habits company it's never
too early to start gift shopping for the
holidays especially because today you
can save big on a gift they'll use every
day raycon wireless earbuds with
seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit you can
start listening right away and keep
listening for hours the audio quality is
amazing except raycon starts at half the
price the new everyday earbuds come with
three new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds
it's best the pure mode there's the
balance mode and they have the bass mode
raycon offers eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life there's also
a built-in mic and you can take calls on
your earbuds at the press of a button so
this holiday season get them something
they can use for calls or music for work
or play at home or on the go trust me
you're going to use them every day go to
byracon.com
honeydew today to unlock exclusive deals
up to 20 off your raycon order but hurry
this offer is available for a limited
time only and you won't want to miss it
that's by raycon.com
honeydew to unlock up to 20 percent off
your ray cons by raycon.com honeydew as
a parent there's nothing better than
watching your child's imagination in
action as they unlock new ways of seeing
the world and little passports offers
award-winning play-based kits to fuel
curiosity through fun hands-on
activities they'll love the feeling of
discovery almost as much as you'll love
watching them explore and whether
they're exploring the science of optical
illusions or art in spain your child
will love the feeling of discovering
something new every month with a little
passport subscription each month little
passport ships kits full of hands-on
activities that let your child take the
reins and exploring the world around
them so this holiday give the young
explorer in your life a world of
adventure get 20 off any new
subscription with promo code honeydew at
littlepassports.com order by december
20th for christmas delivery free
shipping is included that's
littlepassports.com
promo code honeydew make sure you get
that order in by december 20th so you
get it for christmas free shipping is
included again that's
littlepassports.com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the duke there's always something
happening i went out with my mom one
night i come back home
my mom and my mom always has new friends
that's how you know she's toxic she
always got a new best friend so she's
got this new friend i'm not gonna say
her name
but
she's hanging out with my mom all the
time my mom's like she's so cool she's
so fun
i think she's kind of annoying but it's
fine so she were hanging out and um she
she brings over she has a nephew who's
like a little a few years older than me
he
seems off he just seems like um
he's wearing the same clothes i saw
people wearing in the early 2000s he's
wearing the back snap cat the long
shirts he looks like a like an old
florida pill dealer to me
and i'm like oh i hope she didn't bring
her nephew to like so we can hang out
so we're all hanging out and then
everything's fine they go home the next
day me and my mom are
going to downtown together to drink so
we go to downtown we're all out having a
nice drink so we see my mom's friend and
her nephew um and and he buys me a drink
and i'm like uh okay
this is recent right this is
uh within the last two years yeah this
is a pretty recent story and um they
leave like they don't hang out for that
long and me and my mom get pretty drunk
at this point we're having such a good
time we leave this bar we go to get
pizza we're eating pizza we're on
and we're walking we just pay this guy
he's like playing guitar on the sidewalk
and we hit this corner she loves those
musicians she loves she can't stay awake
i felt a little thunderbolt when she
heard the guitar
it pissed her off she was like i don't
know what my stepdad's doing um
we turn the corner and we see her friend
and the nephew making out
wait hard making
that lady's making out with her own neck
with her own nephew no and she's like 50
something and he's like
27 27-28 is this her blood nephew her
blood
nephew the [ __ ] out and they're hard
making they see you see them yes no yes
we run right into them no dude i have a
periscope now weinshank says her and her
mom watched this periscope like over and
over again of the moment me and my mom
caught them and i went live on periscope
and we ran away i go we just caught my
mom my mom's friend making out with
their nephew i was hammered i'm like
telling the whole story sarah's like
it's one of the funniest pair of scopes
ever but like they were making it hard
and then they just looked at us she
grabbed him by the hand and she ran away
and my mom goes
she says her name i'm gonna make up a
name she goes anna
it's your nephew
and she just flips us the burn and runs
away with him
get the [ __ ] out of here a couple weeks
later she just comes back over with him
now and praise him
yes and still pretends it's her nephew
and pretends they're not together and
hangs out and proceeds to drink with us
is it her nephew yes but they're dating
dating they're not just like doing a
weird [ __ ] thing they're actually
they're always together i see them like
five or six more times i have to pretend
i don't know this i'm like it's like
weird it's like oddly like watching
weird porn in real life yeah that is
watching a sexual tension between an
aunt and nephew are they um affectionate
no not in front of you nope not any
meteor hugs or not nope they're just
rolling together
nephew he calls her titi
that is [ __ ]
you know what was disturbing is i went
on our facebook and i saw a picture of
him when he was like 10 and her when she
was like 25.
and she was like i love my nephews
and i'm like that's weird [ __ ] this one
in a few years yeah
but i'm like that's weird that's weird
and to have a relationship it's
like it's different if you stumble upon
a nephew that you didn't know about
and i'm not even gonna defend this it's
all wrong but it's all wrong it would be
better if that wasn't your blood if that
was like your husband's whatever from
that side you consider that a nephew
through marriage you know kind of high
all right but that's that's like your
sibling's child that is [ __ ]
disgusting yeah
man
and then they have her that's what i'm
saying and it wasn't just like she's
like i [ __ ] my nephew once like
they're having a public relationship in
in public i don't know if this is a
really bad detailed ad but he just died
what yeah why i don't know
did she kill him i don't think so i'm
probably from i mean i would assume
drugs
but i don't know if i could say i don't
want to get sued but i don't well are
you going to say assumptions yeah
i'm assuming drugs so now who's she
going to bang the other nephew
running out of family yeah
and you're like this is my uncle i'm
like oh [ __ ] your mom and you what your
mom did you talk to your mom more about
that like this is a newer friend which
is what you said right well the thing
that's [ __ ] up is like when my mom
told me she was like so-and-so's nephew
died she texted me that i'm like that's
not her nephew that's someone she [ __ ]
like we can't can't keep calling him
enough dude no enough
i'm putting a stop to this her boyfriend
her boyfriend
who also happens to be your nephew like
nephew is second it's so disturbing
[ __ ] up you guys saw it that's great
i'll never forget it
it's like saying bigfoot
it's like
that is [ __ ] up
um all right tell me tell me i want to
hear about you're you're uh gator so i
want to hear some college stories you
have some college stories ah college
stories or gator stories you have actual
gator stories actual alligators
i've almost gotten eaten by an alligator
okay so when i was younger i was best
friends with this girl in school um and
her parents went on like a few vacations
a year and my family didn't um so her
parents would always bring i was the
poor brown friend that would go on the
vacation with the white friend i was
i'll tell you right now
well you said your mom's puerto rican
what's your dad's my stepdad's white but
what about your dad my dad is uh white
as well his mom was native american he's
got like very tan skin but he also like
lived in puerto rico he speaks more
spanish than my mom so when i say white
it almost feels wrong because he's like
he almost seems native to me in a way
but he's white um
but um
uh we would go on vacation and one year
we went to this place it was the springs
and florida has these springs that um
you can like canoe in and swim in and
they're really cool
uh and i went with this girl's family
and when i was younger i didn't realize
it but now that i'm older i know that
this woman was an alcoholic
and her husband probably was too and
they drank a lot but i didn't i just
thought they were really fun
when i went on vacation with them um so
during the day the springs are cool and
they're filled with like
hundreds of people and so like it's fine
and they're see-through and you can see
everything but there was this is kind of
weird now that i'm telling the story
this is kind of a weird thing to do
we would swim during the day and then
there was one night that we were hanging
out their mom and her mom was like let's
play truth or dare
and we're like okay and she like dare
and she would always dare us to do silly
things like i knew you'd run around in
your bra around the camper once and it
was like kind of fun and just like you
or maybe weird i don't know a little bit
about that did i get molested
oh no
um no but it was like cute she was just
like hanging out with the girls and we'd
scream and be like okay you know um and
um
then
she dared us to jump into the spring at
night
knowing there be alligators potentially
in there there was no alligators during
the day so that's what i that's why i
thought she thought it was okay
but now that i'm an adult
and i live in florida i would
never even put a child in a dark pool at
night because you never know the gators
get in everything
so the fact that she dared all of her
kids and her kids friends to jump in all
of you not just one person all of us to
go night swimming not just jump in and
jump out we brought tubes
we brought like swimming gear we're
snorkel gear we're going underwater
snorkeling dude
in the middle of the night and the moon
is out i'm on this floaty we all get in
we're like ah and she doesn't get in
she's standing from the side is did this
[ __ ] try to kill me all of you she
tried to kill did she try to kill us
hold on
i'm losing my mind now [ __ ] up
how many kids
me my friend
her little brother
and the two next-door neighbors which
grew up with them they all grew up at
the same time so five children yeah
they're all in splashing away nobody
else and it is like
it is like the size of a blake it is
huge body of water and the only way to
get in is like the stairs wait they kind
of threw us in over the edge of the wall
so the only way to get out is you have
to swim across the leg onto the stairs
or like someone has to pull you up from
like the wall and it kind of hurts it
scrapes your knee and we're in the water
i'm in a tube the kids are all in the
water and i'm in a tube on my stomach
and i'm floating and i'm just watching
the way i've never been in water at
night because my parents didn't want me
to die
so i'm watching the way the moon's
reflecting on the water and it's really
cool to me i've never seen that before
so i'm sort of on my stomach i'm like
10 years old and i'm like watching and
on each side of the reflection i see two
yellow eyes no two pairs probably like
20 feet away you see them like the
just too glowing i i look at the moon i
look down and i see two glowing eyes and
they start coming towards me and then go
under i see nothing
and i fully panicked i don't know how i
got to that wall so fast i i i
did this thing i got to the wall and for
some i don't know how i balance i don't
know how this happened i balanced on
this tube i stood up on it on each side
of it without flipping the tube and
jumped on the wall and dangled from it
until one of them pulled me up and just
screaming and they pulled me out and i'm
having like a panic attack and i'm like
i saw something in water and they're
like there's nothing in the water
there's no gators in here earlier and as
i'm crying i'm not breathing someone
pulls up in a golf cart and he goes you
better get those kids out of there this
place is full of gators at night
god
i don't know how i stood up on the tube
it was like halfway inflated you know
those black ones don't look like donuts
and i don't know how i went from my
stomach to standing on it just to get
away four [ __ ] eyes four eyes both
coming towards me and i swear to god and
then under and the second she pulls me
out and says that she was still like
drying me off with a towel on crying and
someone pulls up
and then and everyone was still in the
water jesus jesus christ yeah and they
start yanking the kids out of the water
i mean every single one of you would
have died if one gator bites it's over
everyone's going yeah they're all coming
over
jesus christ it's weird
that is very yeah i mean the bra thing
is way less dangerous i wouldn't wish i
wish
just molest me dude
could you imagine that my mother getting
that news that i got ate by an alligator
in the middle of the night could you
imagine babysitting kids and and then
you're watching all five of them get
eaten by alligators and you're [ __ ]
right what if i wouldn't have seen that
what if i would have been playing with
the the other kids were all splashing
behind me i was being a weirdo in the
night looking at the moon reflection
then you never would have known he
grabbed you and rolled over and it's
over for you you're done
yeah that's crazy [ __ ] nuts
that lady should not be allowed to
babysit children
god damn
that same day you know what's weird too
that same day during the day so the
springs in florida the the where you can
swim inside where florida are you for
when this is this it must be near
gainesville okay um because that's where
they all are and i think it was called
wakaiva
um
and it's really cool and beautiful and
there are like
springs that are more swampy that you
canoe in and then they go off into clear
springs where like everyone swims where
you can see what's going on and there's
not like the gators don't
this is just what florida says the
gators don't come out when the people
are there they just don't they're more
scared because there's a bunch of people
which is still kind of weird um
but when we were in the canoe area they
made us go on an eight mile canoe trip
we're like kids
and they did flip the canoe right after
we saw an alligator the dad flipped the
canoe
and we all flipped over by accident and
this is i must have had a will
i must have had a will to survive
because the canoe fully flipped
and i held onto it upside down until
they flipped it over again and stayed
and stayed in the [ __ ]
and they both fell out and i remember i
was like it like flipped and flew into a
bush and i was upside down in this marsh
and they like flipped it over
but i'm like were they trying to kill us
now that i'm telling this story
were they trying to kill us that sounds
like it
it [ __ ] sounds like it [ __ ] sounds
like i'm gonna have to hit up that
friend cause she hates her parents now
oh really i follow her on social media
and she just talks about how horrible
they are on social media on social media
and she's like they're horrible people
they've always been horrible people
on social media constantly i have to
check on her i'm like are you okay
um so i'm gonna ask her if they tried to
kill us and i'll get back to you i want
to know because that's [ __ ] up because
now that i'm retelling the story i'm
like i would never there's no way i
could
first i wouldn't flip a canoe that we're
in
after right after seeing an alligator
right after seeing it swim at night
anyway in florida right after seeing an
alligator that was after that they dared
us to jump in the water
so you're how is your relationship with
your mom now um
you know i i
if you
i don't know if you grew up with any
narcissists
but if you have um you don't really
realize it for a long time because they
like trick you into thinking that like
it's
everybody else but them
and so so uh growing up with my mom i
had a really really close relationship
with her and then around like 17 or 18 i
started to like
wise up a little bit um and it got
really rocky for a few years
um and
uh i had like a very
great therapy session one time where i
was told to just like
not even worry about what she's doing
and that has helped a lot good um and
now
i am
we get along um
pretty well but i am trying to change
our relationship from
her depending on me as a friend to her
like giving her boundaries to be my
mother
where i'm like you can't tell me that i
don't want to know this about you
and i will just like hang up and so i'm
working on that currently so our
relationship's fine i mean it's a work
in progress yeah so and how about your
dad are you close with your dad um
my dad i am
close with him like he
this is the thing my dad recently got
sober while he was working on the boat i
think he just finished the boat like a
week ago and i know that because he
started drinking again
so he wasn't working on the boat for
like months and months and he would call
me all the time
and we didn't talk a lot before because
he always only called me when he was
drunk and it's not like he was saying
anything mean or anything it's just like
he talks too much and it's like i just
don't answer because it's like i don't
want to talk to someone that's drunk
it's just not fun yeah um
so we had
it felt like we were getting closer
but now he's drinking again and now i'm
like if i get a call after 9 00 p.m i
know it's midnight back home and i'm
like i don't answer so we don't talk as
much i see so we're kind of close i mean
we're friends me and my parents like i
don't have any like parents i have like
friends
it feels like
so what about your stepdad i mean you
say your things are better now and you i
i caught you saying he actually calls
you and tells you about your mom and
stuff yeah so you have that kind of
relationship where he can call you or he
just doesn't complain i mean we don't
really have a relationship super close
when i see him we get along
i it's so funny because i get along with
any of them because of the work i've
done
it's not really like anything that
they're doing so i'm like yeah we get
along because i choose to but i i see
this meme that goes around a lot that
says um i go to therapy for for the
people in my life that won't yes you
know what i mean i go to i go to deal
with the people in my life that [ __ ]
walk through and learn how to deal with
that so i can still have you in my life
because you are [ __ ] up and won't do
anything about it exactly that's exactly
how i feel except this fight um yeah
that's exactly how i feel totally okay
so
after everything we've talked about
because 16 is a pivotal moment i feel
like in an age for a lot of people going
back and looking at it now what um
advice would you give to your 16 year
old self
um
buy bitcoin
yeah all of it
put all of your money into bitcoin and
just wait
that's it no um
uh yeah i don't know that's a really
hard question i guess um
you know i guess the advice that i would
give to any 16 year old which would be
myself as well is that like
everything sucks sometimes and things
just get better and then they're gonna
suck a little and then they get better
and that's sort of the cycle of life so
don't don't get too down when things
suck right because it's just this is
part of it it's all cyclical it's up and
down and yeah it just gets
people get so down when when things
happen that are bad and i go aren't you
used to this right we've all been it's
uh we've all been doing this forever
it's fine it'll be fun so some people
that's when i i remember sitting here
i'm not sure who a guest was like wow
everything was good it might have been
brooks wheel and until like 25 or 27 i
was like wow you had a decent run you
had a good run you know before it all
started falling off it was way before
that for us you know and you too
obviously
um thank you so much for coming on thank
you for having me doing the show will
you please promote your everything you
want again yeah of course um i gave you
guys my show dates i'm not gonna pull
out my phone again but i'll put them on
my social media you can follow me on
twitter at kimberly congdon on tiktok
and instagram at kim congdon i also
stream on twitch i'm really excited
about that i'm starting to build up my
channel i'm getting a pc
so uh follow me on twitch.tv
queen kong one that's c-o-n-g-one if you
have amazon prime you can subscribe for
free um and i have my own podcast called
broad topics
t-o-p-i-x uh you can find that youtube
itunes stitcher google play anywhere you
find podcast the gas digital network um
and sarah weinchink and i are also
starting a podcast coming out so keep a
lookout for that yeah uh it's sticky
kimmy and shank coming to you soon i
love it i love it uh and thank you so
much for having me this is really really
great i'm glad i'm glad that you came on
this is a great episode thank you um as
always ryan sickler on all social media
ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you